in the war here is now in its third
month and the country says it's in the
very worst
financial condition the head of the
international monetary fund has said
ukraine needs around five billion
dollars a month
just to cover essential services well
joining us
from kiev now is ukraine's finance
minister sergey marchenko good evening
to you and thank you very much for being
with us and we hear
every day about the human cost of this
war just talk to us about the economic
cost because
it must be huge
yes
for sure
our economic losses is
very
drastic and
if you look at figures it's around
300 million
euro per day
it's a
economic of four it's our losses on some
when necessary budget spendings
and if you compare with
possible other losses it will be
bigger even
yeah the world bank i see has said that
the
economy is contracting by 45 percent uh
i mean how are you going to deal with
that long term if this is a protracted
conflict
you see right now we are looking at uh
temporary solution so we need
a bridge to a new normal so to just to
fix the situation for three periods of
these months
we need five
billion us dollars per month
and after that we will
try to fix the situation in a way to
have some predictable macro forecast
till the end of the year and make other
changes maybe in legislation increase
taxes or make some reducing expenses if
needed but of course first and for the
most
for this critical moment of time we need
wins this war so we need
support international support for our
partners
yeah and you rely on them export of
grain and
wheat and so forth that
not happening at all
now much of it
goes to
russia and belarus i understand can you
see that ever
you know coming back that kind of level
of trade
you mean our trade with russia and
belarus or you mean
how we can manage to
cover our
necessary um
export operation with uh other countries
because of our harborough blocks i i
don't understand question
well no if 60 goes to russia and bella
russia you will find you'll have to find
going forward um other markets and are
you confident you can do that when all
this is over
i think that uh we have lower um
the
trade
trade share of our
russia and belarus so
that's why
we can manage to fill this gap with
other countries so now we fully blocked
all possible export
of goods from russia and belarus so
i think that we can manage to
find different other
sources to to fill this gap with the
resources from europe for example
and sergey how worried are you about
losing your access to the sea if russia
manages to cut off odessa as well or
it's already blockading odessa how
worried are you about losing access to
the sea
we earn a great worry of that because
now it blocked all our grain export
and you know there's a storages with
almost 10 million tonnes of for grain
and other
agricultural facilities which we can
manage to
deliver for their uh final destination
so so now we are seeking the rules roots
how to uh export this grain and it's a
very big problem
i don't think it's even for ukrainian
problem it can
absolutely starvation in another part of
the world
because
400 million people depends on our
food and agra products
absolutely and in terms of the damage
sergey to
infrastructure across this country which
is getting worse every day
um have you any idea of the kind of
um
you know
amount of money that the damage is is at
the moment how much it's costing at the
moment do you have any idea
now we are working closely with world
bank and we want
them to provide us very reliable tool
how to estimate these damages
but our
our internal estimation is around since
600
billion us dollars which
we can
now can calculate but of course
to be more reliable we need to
based on some tools and i believe that
world bank tools can support on us to
estimate
losses more carefully
and would you like to see some sort of
you know martial plan for ukraine what i
mean is the west paying you know
helping to pay for a lot of this
damage when this is
when this is over if not russia of
course
we will prefer russia
payment for this damages because it will
be very
adjustable
and of course
we
rely on
assets frozen assets which
is
frozen in eu
united states canada
to be sales in a way to help ukraine to
be rebuked and of course uh we will
support from
reliant support from other countries but
main
our main domain is how managed to save
frozen russian asses to rebuild our
country
okay mr marchenko thank you very much
indeed for being on the program this
evening thank you